Silver State Schools Credit Union the
sponsors of this segment want you to
achieve financial success I spoke to CEO
and president Scott a Arcos to find out
how they can help you
last time we talked we were talking
about your certificate account promotion
and Silver State Schools Credit Union
they kicked off the new year with new
rates now how can the community benefit
from this well we sure have uh kicked it
off and and been very aggressive in
doing that and so
um our certificate account dividend
rates have actually increased and so
we're we're trying to be very very
competitive and really help our members
and non-members out and so at Silver
State Schools Credit Union obviously we
strive to provide the products and
services that will help our members
Achieve Financial success now and in the
future and so you know whether you're
saving for a new car College tuition or
even retirement a certificate accounts a
perfect way to get started and we've got
really right now two options uh Mercedes
for that one's a little bit of a shorter
term and it's 13 months um and that
earns Believe It or Not 4.25 annual
percentage rate
um and and then you you can bump it up
if you want to to a 25 month certificate
and that's at 475 and these are some of
the best CD rates and actually in the
country and so
um so if you're not a member of Silver
State Schools Credit Union uh this would
be a great time to bring uh money over
uh to the credit union and it's uh
obviously a perfect time to join us and
see all that we can do for you not only
on these uh savings accounts but also uh
on our loans and and everything else
that we do for our members those rates
are fantastic and you just said it come
over now so are you saying that those
rates those are not just for existing
members correct it's it's for it's for
existing members and also new members uh
who are bringing money over from other
institutions that add a lot lesser rate
and so and and this is it's it's a
competitive limited time offer we don't
have an end date right now but as you
mentioned it is for new and existing
deposits and so we don't want to limit
that um
um quite frankly we want to make sure
that we're offering it for people that
already have money deposited with us but
also for people that are really
interested in in coming over to us how
does the credit union help those members
who are trying to learn uh more about
managing their finances our members and
non-members can use financial literacy
programs uh that we offer and we've got
a wide range of topics that that will
really set you on a path to Future
financial success
um one of my personal favorites that I
really like um and I and I know you're
very familiar with is our money moves
program
um and so it's a free online Financial
education center that offers interactive
uh courses to help bring uh you know
really to help you learn about things
like managing your finances setting up a
budget or learning about things like the
benefits of owning a home and uh it's
it's a program that's available
um on our website at Silver State eu.com
money moves thank you to Silver State
Schools Credit Union for sponsoring this
segment for more information call
702-733-8820 or visit
silverstatecu.com we'll be right back